I asked Michelle this question like an
hour ago in honorable thieves zinc in
holga are like the most physical
fighters in a showdown between the two
who would win
what did Michelle say well I'll tell you
after you tell me your answer
um I think you know I gotta back my boys
Hank I think zank would win I don't
think it would be an easy win
um I think that zenks failure you know
what no I'm gonna change my answer zenk
would lose but because he let Holger win
in order to be honorable it is exactly
what Michelle said
no way are you serious zinc would
probably let me win because I'm a girl
there we go we know our characters we
know how this works